من هيروشيما باليابان مراسلات الجزيره وجد
وقفي مرحبا وجده معلوما ان على راس
الاولويات خلال اجتماعات مجموعه الدول
السبع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيا والصين
ماذا في تفاصيل
نعم فيما يتعلق بدايه
باوكرانيا الولايات المتحده تحاول ان ان
تخرج هذه القمه ببيان منفصل بحسب مسؤول
امريكي رفيع ببيان منفصل متعلق باوكرانيا
يؤكد هذا البيان وحده الصف داخل دول
المجموعه بتقديم الدعم اللام متناهي
لاوكرانيا في مواجهتها للحرب الروسيه على
اراضيها بالحديث عن الدعم لاوكرانيا هناك
ضغوط تخضع لها الاداره الامريكيه لعده
شهور من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك
الكونجرس الامريكي من اجل تزويد اوكرانيا
بطائرات اف 16
هل الولايات المتحده يعني هي ترفض حتى
اللحظه على الاقل على الصعيد العلني تزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الطائرات الدول الاوروبيه
التي تمتلك هذه واشترتها من الولايات
المتحده
دفعت باتجاه الحصول على موافقه الاداره
الامريكيه بتزويد طائرات اف 16 وبيعها
لاوكرانيا من اجل استخدامها في مواجهتها
للطيران الحربي الروسي الذي يقصف ويحرق
اراضي في اوكرانيا هناك لحظه تحدث عن
احتمال موافقه الاداره الامريكيه لحظه فقط
ما يعضد ما تقولينه
الان تنشر بعض
ربما المعطيات ضمن بيان لقمه الدول السبع
من بينها تقول اذا بانه لا يمكن تحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا دون انسحاب كامل وغير
مشروط للقوات الروسيه وكذلك تنقل رويترز
عن بيان لقمه سبع تقول بانهم يجددون
التزامهم بدعم اوكرانيا ماليا وعسكريا
ودبلوماسيا مهما تطلب الامر كله يصب في ما
قلتيه فيما يتعلق ايضا بالدوري الامريكي
في هذا الصدد
نعم هذا صحيح بالفعل وهذا ما سيؤكد عليه
البيان الختامي وهو وحده الصف بين دول
مجموعه السبع كافه فيما يتعلق بهذا الدعم
الدعم اللامتناهي مهما تطلب ذلك من وقت
بحسب ما علمنا من مسؤول امريكيه رفيع اذا
من ضمن هذا الدعم الحديث والرغبه
الاوروبيه بتقديم او تسليم طائرات اف 16
لاوكرانيا الولايات المتحده هناك تسريبات
تقول بانها قد توافق على هذا الطلب كما
تعلم محمد ليس بامكان الدول التي تشتري
طائرات اف 16 الامريكيه تزويدها لطرف ثالث
مثل اوكرانيا في هذه الحال ما لم توافق
الاداره الامريكيه على ذلك ذلك ان فيها
تقنيات حساسه والولايات المتحده لا تريد
تريد لهذه التقنيه ان تصل الى ايدي خصومها
وبالتالي
تزويد اوروبا اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16
مشروط بموافقه امريكيه وهناك حديث
وتسريبات عن احتمال ان توافق اداره الرئيس
بايدن على هذا الامر طبعا هذا لا يوجد اي
تاكيد رسمي فيما يتعلق بهذا الشان ولكن
هذا مطلب للرئيس الاوكراني منذ عده اشهر
ومنذ عده اشهر نسمع من كبار المسؤولين
تحديدا في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
رفضه الولايات المتحده تزويده اوكرانيا
بهذه الطائرات فهل سيتغير ذلك خاصه مع
حضور الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي الى هنا
الى هيروشيما لحضور احدى والمشاركه في
احدى جلسات هذه القمه هذا ما سننتظر حدوثه
في البيان الختامي بالفعل وجد ومثل ما
ذكرت في مراسله سابقه الرئيس الاوكراني
كان يشارك بحسب كل تسريبات عبر فيديو ولكن
تم تاكيد خبر بانه سيكون متواجدا ربما يوم
السبت او الاحد شكرا جزيلا لوجد وقف في
مراسله الجزيره كانت معنا من هيروشيما في
اليابان